ja Herr Söder sie haben das das große
Thema aufgemacht die die die Frage
neulich auch in diesem ja
bemerkenswerten Interview in der Bild am
Sonntag wir müssen uns um unsere eigene
Sicherheit kümmern 100.000 drohen haben
sie gefordert einen Flugzeugträger ein
atomaren äh
Abwehrschirm wie stellen Sie sich das
konkret alles vor ja zunächst m ganz
klar aus dem was wir gerade gehört haben
besteht eine echte Herausforderung wie
wir s noch nie hatten äh unter den
Innenministern der Länder wird das Thema
vfall im Rahmen des ger ofenschutzes das
er mit angesprochen al der
Verteidigungsfall der Bundes äh
Verteidigungsminister spricht von
kriegsfähigkeit herstellen ich find das
Wort Verteidigungsfähigkeit persönlich
besser kommt aufs gleiche
raus ja weil weil kriegsfähigkeit
beinhaltet die Option zu einem aktiven
Part und ich meine unser Ziel ist klar
uns zu verteidigen unsere
natogrenzen zu schützen unsere eigene
Freiheit zu schützen
deswegen glaube ich dass wir uns drüber
klar werden müssen in welchem Zustand
ist die Bundeswehr wenn wenn es eintritt
was wir befürchten ab kann ja auch ganz
anders gehen aber wenn der Schutz der
Amerikaner weniger wird das betrifft
übrigens nicht nur die ganzen Fragen der
Waffen wenn sie allein dran denken was
Geheimdienste und terrorfragen betrifft
im Grunde genommen hängt ganz Europa an
den geheimdiensterkenntnissen der
Vereinigten Staaten sollte das kürzer
werden oder weniger werden wird
schwierig wir wissen dass die Militärs
selber nicht möchten dass man abzieht
weil die amerikanischen Militärs sehen
auch insbesondere die Basis in Europa
übrigens auch wichtig an nicht n Europa
zu schützen sondern auch als Rück Gebiet
als Brückenkopf in andere Teile der Welt
insofern waren die Militärs auch schon
von den ersten plen Trumps eher sehr
zurückhaltend würden sie natürlich
befolgen müssen in der Befehlskette also
wenn es passiert dass wegen Mangel der
Unterstützung der
Ukraine Russland in diesem Konflikt in
irgendeiner Form siegt wird der Appetit
wird der Druck wird die Erpressbarkeit
Europas und das Interesse Russlands
stärker an die natogrenzen ranzurücken
erkennbar wird er jetzt schon gespielt
in Litau und wenn die Amerikaner sich
zurückziehen sei es auch nur durch die
Äußerung wie sie es zurecht angesprochen
haben ich stell die NATO mal ein
bisschen in Frage muss es alles sein äh
ergibt sich eine schwierige Situation
darauf muss man sich vorbereiten wir
haben in Deutschland letztes Jahr die
zeitenwände ausgerufen wir sind im
Moment eher an dem zeitenwändchen also
richtig ist noch nicht viel passiert das
heißt es muss in mehreren Stufen gedacht
werden Stufe ein ist äh die maximale
materialausstattung die nach wie vor
nicht so funktioniert es fehlt Material
es fehlt massiv Material K Ken wir das
einmal konkret machen also angenommen
der neue Bundes heißt Markus Söder ja
oder Friedrich Matz oder Hendrik wüst
oder was nein wir spielen jetzt mal
Markus Söder bundeskan ich glaube das
ist die Union wir spielen die Union wir
spielen Markus Söder ja also wir machen
jetzt hier diese Spielchen
im wir machen jetzt kein Kanzlerkandidat
Monopol sondern wir reden jetzt einfach
mal die Frage sie werden verantwortlich
für Deutschland und für dieses neue
Deutschland Gefühl dass wir
offensichtlich alle sind verantwortlich
dafür und man W es auch andere auch
drüber reden wir brauchen eine voll
Ausstattungs auf voll ausgestattete
Bundeswehr mit normalen Material Panzer
Artillerie Material Munition hab schon
bei Munition Probleme wenn wir ehrlich
sind also maximale Ausstattung der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit erstens zweitens
neue Strukturen ich war vor Weihnachten
auch in Israel und ein Teil des Erfolges
kann man gar nicht vorstellen war dass
die Hamas mit sogar einfachen drohen die
Sicherheitsanlagen der Israelis
überwunden hat so konnten sie dann auch
eindringen also wir brauchen sieht man
auch jetzt im in kiefev was mit Drohnen
anstellb wir brauchen massiv eigene
Drohnen e sagen Sie z. was was für
Drohnen sollen das sein ja schutzdrohnen
schutzdrohnen für uns Drohnen die
im Flugbereich tätig sind Drohnen die
abfangen können also das ist im Prinzip
ganz normale Entwicklung die wir haben
müssen dafür sind wir zu wenig wir
brauchen drittens dann neben der
konventionellen Ausrüstung die Klärung
bleibt der atomare Schirm also bleibt
der Amerikaner wenn der atomare Schirm
der Amerikaner bleibt dann haben wir
möglicherweise das Pro Problem ob er ob
er glaubwürdig in der in der
Abschreckung ist ja aber das ist das
eine das zweite ist es fehlt übrigens
und es muss dringend verändert werden es
fehlt bis heute eine Antwort auf den
französischen Vorschlag was den Atom am
Schirm betrifft über den man dann reden
müsste aber so zielführend ist ich habe
mir das die Woche jetzt gedacht beim
Staatsakt für Wolfgang Schäuble man
spürt geradezu die Distanz und und und
und und die nicht Greifbarkeit zwischen
marcron und Scholz ist ein schwerer
Fehler dass wir selbst inner Europa dass
die deutsch-französische Freundschaft
nicht so funktioniert als Achse zu dem
Thema also müssen wir uns um die atomare
Frage auch beschäftigen und das dritte
das ist dann sozusagen ergänzend als
letzter Punkt natürlich müssen wir auch
drüber reden ob wir genügend
Bundeswehrsoldaten haben da gibt's ja
unterschiedliche Pläne und Ideen es gibt
das schwedische Modell wird überlebt ich
glaube persönlich dass auf 7 Jahre
vorwärs gehen auch mit einer anderen
Struktur als wir das jetzt haben eine
Wehrpflicht sinnvoll ist sie selber
waren ja glaube ich auch auch
ich gebjäger ja und Funker ja ich war
bei der Bundeswehr war bei der
Bundeswehr was haben sie da gemacht ich
war im transportbalum
27 Lastwagenfahrer unter anderem ja
Munition Gefahren Munition Gefahren
Munition alles was was explodieren kann
noch wenig Sekunden da gab so Unfall
Merkblätter da stand drauf wenn Unfall
passiert schnell weg so das waren damals
kenne ich gar nicht das sind sie ja das
bin ich ja ja das bin ich von sind sie
sind sie auch mal geflogen als waren
beim her da fliegt man nicht auf der
Stra na ja das hier was ist das hier ja
das ist ein superfoto ja ja das
ist die CSU Variante von topgun aber
sind sie da selber geflogen oder tun sie
nur so ne ich tue auch nicht so ich
sitze halt im Flieger Olf Scholz war
letzt den auch da sind sie mitgeflogen
nein nein nein nein fliegt da nicht mit
ist ja n für uns nein nur fürs Foto
einmal rein und wieder raus das war eine
Bitte ja weil wir uns dazu bekennen für
die ja aber sieht gut aus find schon ich
find dann sind wir schon zwei schne Jae
dass sie ja ich weiß dass sie auf
Schönheit auch wert lien also jetzt noch
mal zurück zu den relevanten Dingen über
die wir da reden und das dritte ist dann
eben gibt ja manche Diskussion wie
allgemeine Dienstpflicht sozus jed das
so ein Beitrag leisten da bin ich etwas
zurückhalten bei der allgemeinen
Dienstpflicht weil ich glaube dass die
verfassungsrechtlich schwer umsetzbar
ist was schnell geht geht die
werrpflicht denn dies n ausgesetzt also
das wäusagen das sind die Dinge reden
mus ich überg ger wo fangen wir an
werrpflicht würden Sie sagen nur Frauen
nur Männer ich würde die bundesw
natürlich komplett öffnen für für Männer
und Frauen aber ich würde sie in der
Pflicht bei den jungen Männern belassen
warum ich glaube dass das
also erstm ist es ist es schneller
umsetzbar zum zweiten auch glaube ich
dass dieses Argument das immer
herrschte die ganzen Strukturen die
ganzen Strukturen zu organisieren
für Frauen eine Verpflichtung würde ich
nicht machen weil ich finde das ä in der
unterschiedlichen lebungsplanung der
unterschiedliche Akzente sind z wari
immer die Begründung warum man das nicht
gemacht hat und schneller zu
organisieren ist es für junge Männer das
ist interessant ich meine oder schau ich
bin völlig offen aber off wenn alle wenn
alle die Pflicht haben wollen auch für
Frauen gerne ich würd es in demem ersten
Schritt nicht machen ich würd es erst
einmal bei den jungen Männern also also
schlüssig erscheint mir die Begründung
noch nicht das ging irgendwie schneller
und so weiter also normalerweise sind
Frauen ja die
flexibleren wenn dann für alle das wäre
das wäre mein petitum aber ich sehe
derzeit nicht
finden sie es wirklich ja auf jeden Fall
s die einen so die anderen so die ander
die anderen sagen aber wenn dann für
alle aber ich seh in im im im Grunde
sind sie doch derzeit ziemlich allein
also alle die sich mit Bundeswehr
beruflich beschäftigen sagen das macht
zurzeit gar keinen Sinn also Boris
bestisturius z.B Eva
Högel in aus der Bundeswehr selber
kommen Zweifel weil das ist ein Irrer
Aufwand also man braucht Ausbilderin
dafür das kostet Agnes stagzimmermann
meint eine zweistellige Milliardensumme
kann ich nicht nachprüfen aber diese
ganze Prioritätenliste die ähm sie auch
vorgeschlagen haben eigentlich gibt's
auch andere Prioritäten als junge Leute
heranzuziehen und sagen lernt jetzt
erstmal richtig Gewehre zu putzen und im
gleichritt zu marschieren eigentlich
brauchen wir doch was anderes zur Zeit
ich weiß also ich glaube zum ein Mal ist
es so wenn man die Prioritäten sieht ist
die das Material die Herstellung der
jetzigen Ausstattung der bundesw
natürlich die Priorität hab ich so
gesagt ähm ich glaube das mittelfristig
die Frage tatsächlich das solollstärke
bei einem anderen Form einer
Landesverteidigung die wieder eine Rolle
spielt als das was wir bislang als
verteidigungsbfften eine wichtige Rolle
spielt ich glaube drüber hinaus dass es
ähm natürlich mit anderen Strukturen
sein müsste also man müsste in der Tat
es anders organisieren auch die
Musterung müsste anders sein die Frage
der Zeit wir haben mit Militärs geredet
also 7 Monate kann eine zeitaachse sein
in der so monef 7 Monate kann auch
länger sein aber 7 Monate muss schon
mindestens sein damit da geht's auch
nicht nur um Gewehre putzen da stellt
man sich die bundeswr ein bisschen zu
einfach vor ist nur Gewehr pututzen ist
Frau ja das weiß ich nicht das ich finde
die Klischees passen jetzt der
Ernsthaftigkeit nicht voll ähm sondern
da geht's ja auch um technische Systeme
die Frage wie man das wie man den die
verteidigungsstruktur organisiert wir W
über cybersicherheit reden drohen was
aber was ich doch sagen ist doch wir
brauchen eigen Spezialistinnen oder ja
aber auch auch das lässt sich schon auch
von der sollstärkeieren weil wir nicht
die genüg genügende Personal für die
Bundeswehr auf da haben und die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit in der Breite
herzustellen und letzter Grund und das
finde ich schon wichtig ich finde auch
wichtig dass wir eine eine andere
Beziehung haben viele junge Menschen zum
starta ich finde dieses Bekenntnis zu
Gemeinschaft zum Staat wichtig wir
hätten ein Bundeswehr wir hätten auch
wieder satzdienst beides ist für unser
Land und auch für viele junge Menschen
gut Frau major zwei Fragen die erste
Frage Frauen ich bin da auch nicht auf
ihrer Seite weil ich auch mit Blick auf
den Krieg in der Ukraine beispielsweise
diese ganzen Menschen ich habe auch
einige davon getroffen sind so junge it
Spezialisten die dann plötzlich Drohnen
fliegen also das heißt die sind ganz
ganz entscheidend für das was da an der
Front passiert die kämpfen aber nicht
selber an der Front od es sind auch
junge Leute die sagen ne pass auf also
Gewehr fass ich nicht an aber wenn es
darum geht russische schützengrben
anzugreifen mit Hilfe einer Drohne dann
bin ich genau der richtige Mann das
können natürlich auch Frauen wenn sie
aus itbereichen in irgendeiner Form
kommen ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass
die Frage werficht ja oder nein die
komplett falsche Frage ist ich glaub die
Frage ist welches Problem wollen wir
eigentlich lösen wollen wir das Problem
lösen es gibt 180 000° wir wollen
200.000 Soldaten haben also ist es eine
Frage ist eine personalfüllungsfrage
oder es ist die Frage die sie eben
angesprochen haben wie können wir
eigentlich die werttüchtigkeit oder die
Gesamtverteidigung des Landes stärken
oder ist die Frage wie integrieren wir
die verschiedenen Bevölkerungsgruppen
für mich ist die werrpflicht für keins
der drei Fragen die Lösung wenn es darum
geht mehr Personal ranzukriegen ist die
Frage wollen wir Masse oder wollen wir
Expertise mit einem Zwangsdienst wo
eigentlich keiner so richtig hin will
kriegen sie wieder Masse noch Expertise
dazu kommen die Argumente die sie
gemacht haben das dauert extrem lange
wir haben die Strukturen nicht mehr so
wenn es darum geht wir wollen eigentlich
die werttüchtigkeit die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Landes
herstellen da geht's ja darum da geht's
ja nicht nur um Zivil geht ja nicht nur
militärisches da geht's genauso um
ziviles da geht's darum kann
irgendjemand im Notfall kann irgendein
it-szialist das Land mit schützen oder
wie können wir Energiesicherheit
herstellen oder so und das kriegen sie
auch nicht durch den Zwangsdienst hin
weil sie bestimmte Bereiche brauchen und
der dritte die dritte Idee zu sagen wie
können wir eigentlich das Land besser
zusammenbringen vielleicht auch eine
bessere Identifikation das kriegen sie
ja auch nicht mit dem Zwangsdienst hin
und deshalb ist glaube ich die Frage
immer welches Problem will ich lösen
wenn es darum geht wir brauchen mehr
Rekruten für die Armee dann ist die
Frage gibt es gezielte Programme für
cyberspezialisten oder für bestimmte
Sprachen die Amerikaner haben eine Zeit
lang als in Afghanistan waren bestimmte
Programme für bestimmte
sprachspezialisten aufgelegt wenn es
darum geht dass wir die Resilienz also
die wertüchtigkeit des Landes
wiederherstellen wollen dann müsste man
eher an so eine Art resilienzpraktikum
von jung bis alt männlich weiblich
denken also ich glaube einfach dass
immer die Frage ist was wollen wir
eigentlich damit erreichenkum und
deswegen oder wie auch immer sie das
nennen aber ichpraktikum ist glaub ich
nicht die Idee lass mich ganz kurz mal
ausreden also ich glaube die Frage ist
deshalb finde ich die Idee mit dem
schwedischen Modell ganz gut das
schwedische Modell ist interessant weil
alle gemustert werden das hat den
interessanten Nebeneffekt dass der Staat
weiß wer eigentlich da ist dass die die
Strukturen dafür für den vfall oder wie
auch immer da sind und gezogen werden
dann nur die die wirklich wollen das
sind
bring die Frage ist doch am Ende ganz
wie viele werden dann tatsächlich
gezogen also beim schwedischen Modell
reicht es die Frage ist wie viel für das
deutsche Modell sein würden aber wir
müssen noch mal fragen wir wollen ja
nicht nur Masse haben was gerade fehlt
sind beispielsweise in im cyberbereich
enorm viele Spezialisten die kriegen sie
aber nicht wenn sie einfach sagen ihr
müsst jetzt morgen kommen glaube wir
müssen viel mehr über en wie man das
Personal kriegt was die Bundeswehr
wirklich braucht darf ich einmal die R
ich w anders sagen weil für mich all die
Fragen sie stellen sind völlig richtig
aber sie haben jetzt praktisch richtige
Antwort gegeben weil sagen dafür taugt
das nicht und das nicht und das nicht
und dann machen wir am Ende
resilienzpraktikum ne hab nicht gesagt
ich habe gesagt schwedisches Modell ja
das schwedische Modell funktioniert dann
nicht glaube ich jedenfalls bin auch
gespannt ob es in Schweden so bleibt
wenn der Ansatz der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit größer wird wenn
wir keine Erhöhung der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit brauchen weil die
Bedrohung Lage nicht stärker wird weil
die Herausforderung an den Grenzen nicht
stärker werden der
Bundesverteidigungsminister hat
unterschrieben eine Brigade in litaauen
aufzustellen aus der bundesbehörmann ist
sehr schwer zu organisieren dass das
überhaupt geht
Personal Material schwierig als auch von
der von der von der Zahl der Soldaten
wenn wir und es geht ja um die
mittelfristigkeit es geht nicht um um
jetzt sofort wenn wir mittelfristig
überlegen wie wir insgesamt uns stärker
verteidigungsfäer machen können dann ist
natürlich die Technik dann ist natürlich
das Material dann brauchst doch Experten
die übrigens nicht nur für ein paar
Monate sondern vielleicht im Beruf bei
der Bundeswehr machen als Berufssoldaten
dann arbeiten weil es hilft jetzt auch
nichts einen einen itszialisten Z der
mal für drei Monate da ist da bin ich
völlig beiinen aber du brauchst trotzdem
zum Aufrechterhaltung einer
militärischen Infrastruktur und auch so
hart es klingenm auch eine
entsprechenden äh Struktur die eine
Front äh tatsächlich
sichern können brauchst du auch äh ähm
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und deswegen
ist es ein Bestandteil und ich würde es
nichts erreden ganz im Gegenteil und ein
schwedisches Modell wo ich zwar weiß wer
da ist aber nicht kommt wird am Ende
genau diese Frage nicht lösen wir haben
jetzt mit mehreren Möglichkeiten
versucht die ich übrigens gerne auch
ausweiten würde den freiwilligen Ansatz
zu erhöhen also sagen wir mal durch dass
man Numerus klausus nicht so gilt fürs
Studium oder Praktiker nicht geleistet
werden müssen immer sonst hat da wäre
ich sehr dafür dass sind wir auch noch
viel zu schwach da können wir noch mehr
machen aber mittelfristig wenn sich die
Frau Frage stellt ich sag's mal ganz
banal vielleicht gewinnt der Russe und
geht der Amerikaner so mal etwas knapp
von dann stellt sich die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit übrigens auch
finanziell in einer ganz anderen Form
dann werden wir über über Geld in einer
anderen Form reden müssen als bislang
und deswegen klug überlegen ein Plan
machen die Wahrheit ist doch wir haben
vor einem Jahr die Zeitenwende
ausgerufen sehr viel ist nicht passiert
auch wenn sich der Verteidigungsminister
erkennbar bemüht so würde ich das sagen
aber in der Struktur kommt Deutschland
nicht voran und deswegen braucht es da
noch mal
DAF noch mal fragen psychologisch Frage
an die Runde sind wir wären wir als Land
um danach auch von dem Thema wegzugehen
dafür bereit also wenn ich höre wir
haben versucht glaube ich zwei
Munitionsfabriken neu zu bauen hat nicht
geklappt na lokalen Widerstand
gescheitert ja weil die Menschen vor Ort
gesagt haben wollen wir hier nicht so
das ist doch eine weit verbreitete
Haltung in Deutschland mit mit Krieg mit
Waffen mit all diesen Dingen und ist
auch nachvollziehbar wollen wir nicht zu
tun zurückgeht und guckt
an dem nachdem Russland die Ukraine
überfallen hatte und zeitenwenderede im
Scholz die zeitenwenderede im Bundestag
hielt ähm da gab's ja eine breite
Zustimmung und es gab auch in der
Bevölkerung eine breite Zustimmung zu
sagen zu Waffenlieferung ich weiß nicht
in ihrer Sendung wurde damals diskutiert
warum liefern wir nicht mehr nicht
schneller nicht weiter nicht höher und
diese Stimmung das das klingt jetzt so
als wä das irendwie so so ein
Wettlauf fr Stimmung hat sich zum Teil
Position vers ukra sagen will wenn wir
in der akuten Bedrohungssituation wären
dann würde sich die Stimmung auch wieder
drehen die Frage wie werden wir
verteidigungsfähig auf lange Sicht und
nachhaltig da hat ja Frau major gerade
die richtigen Fragen aufgeworfen das
lässt sich also werpflicht gingt immer
gut jeder weiß was gemeint es kann man
sich schön ang diskutieren aber Herr
Söder hat ja gerade gesagt das ist eine
mittelfristige Lösung das ist nichts was
uns jetzt unmittelbar also wenn
überhaupt wäre das eine mittelfristige
Lösung das ist nichts was uns jetzt akut
helfen würde also es gilt andere
Bereiche auch in den Blick zu nehmen und
nur noch eine Frage zur Bundeswehr wie
wie kriegen wir es hin dass mehr
Menschen sich für den Beruf als Soldaten
begeistern
dieses Problem teilt die Bundeswehr im
übrigen mit allen anderen Branchen also
das ist fachkräftteemangel gibt's
überall also wir könnten auch sagen
Zwangsdienst in der Pflege da haben wir
genau das gleiche Problem ist jetzt
nicht Verteidigung aber generell muss
man doch über die Bundeswehr hinaus
kriegen gucken und und sehen wie wird
sie als Arbeitgeber attraktiv begeistern
wir junge Menschen für Berufe die wir
offenbar brauchen da W ein Satz dazu
sagen weil das ist schon sehr wichtig
was ich sagen also nächst mal glaube ich
Teil iche der Auffassung wenn sich die
Lage zuspitzt ändert sich auch das
Bewusstsein ich Erin mich in sung glaube
ich bin wo Anton Hofreiter ja die
gesamten Waffensysteme aufgezählt hat
was was wirklich sehr beeindruckend war
für spätere berufliche Verwendungen aber
die Wahrheit ist wenn mehr passiert
gibt's auch mehr Bewusstsein nur können
wir natürlich unsere Strategie die wir
dann brauchen langfristig nicht von
aktuellen dre Monat Stimmungen abhäng
also brauchen eine Strategie erstens
zweitens das Argument die Bundeswehr ist
ein Beruf wie viele andere das kenne ich
über viele JRZ ich glaube das ist nicht
ganz zutrifft denn die Möglichkeit ein
der whrpflicht muss man die Wehrpflicht
die ist ja deswegen überhaupt nur
zulässig weil es am me überragend hohes
Schutzgut geht nämlich die
Landesverteidigung weil normalerweise zu
sagen jemand zu verpflichten zwangsweise
einen Dienst ein die bei der Bundeswehr
waren also sag mal so die wussten dass
das jetzt nicht nur holid war also das
da gab's schon also wenn wenn dass man
damals nach dem Abitur eingezogen wurde
die die die die die die
Klassenkameradinnen damals die fuhren
länger in den Urlaub man selber war der
Bundeswehr da gab es nich auch tolle
Momente aber es gab auch sehr viel
Herausforderung ganz ehrlich und sag mal
so früh um 5 Uhr früh um 5 Uhr aus
Mutters Schlaf geweckt zu werden mit dem
mit dem berühmten Pfiff und ruf
jedenfalls bei uns Kompanie Aufstehen
wird nie einer vergessen der da war so
ich sagen aber trotzdem das kannst du
nur be Gründen weil es um ein Schutzgut
geht nämlich die Landesverteidigung weil
die ein überragendes ist jetzt ist
Pflege auch wichtig um Gottes Willen
viele andere Bereiche aber das ist der
einzige Grund warum man solche eine
Pflicht normieren kann und es geht
natürlich viel mit freiwilligen Anreizen
aber bestimmten Punkt wenn uns das
Personal nicht genügend da wäd zur
Landesverteidigung und wir definieren
das so dann ist die Wehrpflicht
verfassungsrechtlich okay sie ist
derzeit ausgesetzt und kann jederzeit
wieder belebt werden anders organisiert
auf jeden Fall bin ich dafür mm aber ich
glaube schon dass es eine ein wichtiger
Punkt ist um und da sage ich das
Ergänzen dazu die Komplexität der Themen
ist klar aber auch um diese Bindung an
diese Demokratie und diesen Staat und
das Einstehen dafür auch noch mal zu
dokumentieren Frau maor bitte um kurze
Antwort weil ich gerne das Thema noch
bisschen auf das ist übrigens einer der
Vorteile von dem schwedischen Modell
alle die die gemustert werden müssen
darüber nachdenken will ich es oder will
ich es nicht und damit kommen die
Debatten auch zusagen in die ganzen
Familien die ganzen Menschen zurück dass
man überlegt was bedeutet mir das
eigentlich das ist das eine und das
andere ist dass eine
wertüchtige kriegstüchtige Armee auch
immer eine wertüchtige Gesellschaft
erfordert eben weil wenn ich das
Beispiel Russland nehme Russland ist
außenpolitisch revisionistisch und will
Grenzen verschieben die sind aber
genauso gut innenpolitisch
revisionistisch und wollen die liberale
freitliche Grundordnung zurückbauen das
heißt wir brauchen sowohl die
außenpolitische Verteidigungsfähigkeit
wir brauchen es aber auch für die
Gesellschaft nach innen und ich glaube
das sollten deshalb ist es finde ich
diesen Fokus rein auf das mit ische
wirklich zu klein noch mal bin ich ein
bisschen ander Meinung ich finde dieses
kriegstüchtig was der Minister was derus
gesagt hat natürlich schockt das ein
bisschen aber das kickt uns raus aus der
Komfortzone und zwingt uns zu überlegen
was heißt das eigentlich wofür sich
verteidigen womit und das geht nur mit
der gesamten Gesellschaft die dahinter
steht aber mit welcher letzten
Konsequenz das ist ja die Frage und weil
wir gerade dabei sind wie man sowas auch
politisch
dann verkaufen ist vielleicht ein
bisschen die falsche Vokabel aber
letztenendes geht's schon darum ne wir
wir reden auch hier in der Sendung
regelmäßig über die Frage wie hoch sind
eigentlich Renten in Deutschland
beispielsweise wir reden über die Frage
wie hoch sind eigentlich mieten in
Deutschland also die große soziale Frage
wer bezahlt die Pflege all diese Dinge
so ein
Flugzeugträger den sie auch sich
vorstellen könnten wissen Sie was der
kostet ungefähr kosten zig Milliarden
weil der
Flugzeugträger auf ihre Spielchen lassen
wir da nicht ein aber wenn Sie ein
Flugzeug könen Sie mus ja aber da können
sie mit Summen von mehren 30 40 50
Milliarden schon rechnen Flugzeugträger
die ganzen Begleitschiffe das eine
riesige Flotte die dahinter steht das
wäre auch jetzt nichts was die
Bundeswehr leih kann wobei es
interessant ist dass viele andere Länder
in Europa Flugzeugträger haben wir haben
keines gut wir haben die fog
aber wir sind insgesamt da nicht
ausgestattet ich würde ein
Flugzeugträger flugzeugträgermelle auf
europäische nicht für die Bundeswehr
aber solche Modelle zu stärken wäre für
Europa glau ich seh sehr sinv also ich
ahne was sie meinen als es in Gaza oder
um Gaza ging also ich war Isel und dann
ganz klare positionieren warum die
hisbolla nicht so schießen würde ihr
Raketen wie sie könnte liegt an den
amerikanischen flugzeugtr genau ich habe
damals so eine Karikatur gesehen die so
sinngemäß sagte die Amerikaner schicken
einen Flugzeugträger und die deutschen
schicken einen
Bedenkenträger das ist sozusagen so ein
bisschen die die Art und Weise wie wir
da sehen werden aber noch mal die Frage
der Kosten
äh nur die Baukosten also dafür so ein
Ding 13 Milliarden
äh die äh Entwicklungskosten weit über
100 Milliarden wir reden über Gerald
Ford Klasse ja die richtig großen
Betriebskosten für so ein Lebenszyklus
weit über 100 Milliarden dann haben wir
noch nicht gesprochen über die Frage ist
da die F16 oder die F35 oder
Hubschrauber was auch immer drauf bis zu
90 äh Flugzeuge da reden wir jeweils
über entweder 30 Millionen Dollar oder
80 bis 90 Millionen Dollar das heißt da
geht so richtig richtig viel Geld geht's
noch um die Frage der Begleitschiffe und
die Lieferzeit haben sie eine Ahnung
Lieferzeit ungef ist ja alles das hab
noch wir sind hin
erziehungsfernsehen wir sind nicht beim
beim bei ad Alpha sondern geht's ja um
die politische ne so schön ist also wir
wollen doch Dinge erklären und verstehen
nee wir wollen aber auch ne wir wollen
auch erklären entweder erkennen wir an
dass wir verteidigt werden müssen wir
müssen es auch nicht da bin ich bei nein
das sind sie nicht bei mir haben sie
andere
auung ja das stimmt manm das ist nein
ich bin völlig bei die Frage dass man
den Leuten wenn man so etwas politisch
fort morgen haben wir SAS das do Quatsch
hat da keiner gesagt formulieren Sie nee
alles mittelfristig und langfristige
Projekte nur das ist jetzt typisch wir
fangen jetzt die Diskussion überlegen
was verteidigungsfähig ist es wichtig
dass wir nordostsee ist es wichtig dass
wir insgesamt unsere europäische Ruten
sichern in der Welt auch verliefern ist
es sinnvoll ja oder nein ja das brauchen
wir da bin ich auch dafür alle
demonstrieren dafür müssen wir machen
und aber wie geht es ja das kost ne das
darf man nicht machen und und wer nee
das DF man nicht machen und das DF man
nicht machen das wir neigen dazu das ist
das was sie sagten die geistige
internationale werrfähigkeit haben wir
nicht lieber soll die ander machen wenn
es die Amerikaner für uns machen ist ja
super wenn der Trump nicht gewinnt
bleibt vielleicht viele so aber wenn der
Trump gewinnt stehen wir schneller als
wir denken vor Fragen die die wir
beantworten müssen auch im europäischen
Verbund übrigens Britten Franzosen ich
glaube sogar die Italiener hab ein
Hubschrauberträger es gibt ja auch
andere Möglichkeiten die man es machen
kann aber wir müssen uns doch mal
überlegen wo gehen wir denn hin die Welt
verändert sich fundamental und wir
Europäer fallen immer weiter zurück und
ähm wir geben uns Mühe wir streiten
untereinander wir machen tolle Dinge in
Europa mit Gesetzen und und was weiß ich
alles für Verordnungen tolle Leute sind
wir aber wenn es ab ernst wird nimmt uns
keine ernst weil wir nicht bereit sind
Entscheidung zu treffen und dann am Ende
W wer wir Entscheidung treffen und ich
sage ihn heute voraus viele Dinge die
wir machen mal alleine würde ich jetzt
etwas polemisch sein würde ich sagen da
ich im heizgesetz mit der
Kindergrundsicherung die nichts bringt
und ein übertriebenen Bürgergeld
genügend Möglichkeiten ein Grundstock zu
haben sowas zu machen wer besser das
mache ich aber nicht weil ich nicht so
bin wie sie das and W das alles ab dann
hätten sie noch kein Flugzeugträger nein
haben wir natürlich noch nicht aber wir
wir müssen ja anfangen zu über der
Flugzeugträger ist doch nur ein Beispiel
dafür und auch in einer
stufenentwicklung es ist echt typisch
dass wir versuchen alles immer dann
schlecht oder klein sind doch ein die
Idee zu
sagagen ein Plan
heißt es fehlt ja jetzt an Munition es
fehlt ja jetzt an Artillerie es fehlt ja
an den versprochenen ganzen Dingen erste
Stufe dies zu schaffen genau zweite
Stufe Drohnen du brauchst eine
drohnenarmee zur
Sicherung sonst kauft ja kauft ja auch
Putin mittlerweile vom Iran die drohen
um da entsprechend ttig zu werden wird
jetzt auch von Nordkorea und anderen
kauft dritte Stufe ist
dann beispielsweise die Wehrpflicht dann
eben in der Frage der Struktur der
Bundeswehr parallel dazu was ist mit dem
atomaren Schirm in Europa Joschka
Fischer hat vor wenigen Tagen glaube im
Spiegel diese Frage gestellt und die
Frage welche großen Projekte Ken noch
dazu
Europa oder auch Deutschland wir
brauchen eigene Atomwaffen ja zunächst
einmal der atomare Schirm der Amerikaner
ist das Beste was wir haben können wenn
der bleibt super wenn der atomare Schirm
der Amerikaner nicht mehr da wäre müssen
wir als Europäer überlegen was ist
unsere Abschreckung und zwar glaubwürdig
reicht der französische Schirm
ist es sinnvoll dass Deutschland unter
diesen französischen Schirm geht sollen
wir da nur bezahlen dürfen wir
mitentscheiden sind die Fragen warum
gibt es darüber keine Gespräche zwischen
Scholz und marcron beispielsweise und am
Ende stünde die Frage gibt es drüber
hinaus eine weitere europäische Idee
dazu nur die Gedanken muss man sich
jetzt machen weil sie haben mir in einem
Punkt völlig recht alles dauert aber die
Gefahren kommen schneller als wir denken
und deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt auch
überlegen wie es geht okay